wenn aus einer idee ein gesetz werden
soll braucht es jemanden der dafür
kämpft andere überzeugt mehrheiten
beschafft der impfpflicht fehlt dieser
machtvolle jemand der der sie
vorgeschlagen hat im november versteckt
sich hinter dem parlament es ist gut
dass die von mir auch in absprache mit
all meinen freunden der regierung auf
den weg gebrachte debatte über eine
impfpflicht wir reden über den november
jetzt
konkretisiert wird das war von
vornherein so geplant dass es sich dabei
um eine debatte im deutschen bundestag
handeln soll
selbsternannte freunde das ist
schönfärberei dafür dass der freund
einen so allein dastehen lässt es gibt
keinen antrag der koalition
eine impfpflicht ist kein vorhaben der
koalition
ich selbst werde mir ansehen welche
unterschiedlichen optionen es gibt
bundeskanzler minister niemand wird aus
rücksicht auf die fdp mit der macht
seines amtes die union versucht die
lücke zu nutzen fordert immer wieder
einen gesetzentwurf vom bundeskanzler
pfeift die eigenen leute zurück keine
vorschläge machen der druck soll ganz
bei scholz landen gewissensentscheidung
abgesagt was war bei masern was war bei
der teil- impfpflicht das waren alles
keiner medizin ethischen entscheidung es
ist eine politische entscheidung wir
sehen das in österreich dass die
bundesregierung dort voran geht die
parteien aus der mitte mit nimmt das
hätte ich mir auch von der neuen ampel
regierung erhofft ich würde gerne von
der cdu/csu mal wissen wie viele
abgeordnete sich dort positionieren und
nicht immer nur eine aufforderung hören
olaf scholz soll jetzt ein gesetzentwurf
vorlegen wenn die bundesregierung
endlich unsere fragen beantworten würde
dann hätten wir auch schon was
vorgeschlagen
lange wird auch die union sich nicht
mehr drücken können mittwoch ist
orientierungs debatte mit bislang wenig
konkrete
wolfgang kubicki hat sich früh
positioniert mit ihm keine impfpflicht
eine ampel gruppe um den grünen janosch
dahmen wirbt für eine pflicht ab 18
jahren andere hoffen auf dynamik in der
debatte
ich sehe ein kommunikationsdesaster und
ich sehe jetzt eine
entscheidungssituation bist du für den
frieden ja oder nein und ich glaube dass
das genau nicht geht deswegen ist eine
orientierungs debatte gut aber
orientierungs debatte muss auch heißen
dass ist offen ist welche entscheidungen
getroffen sind im übrigen auch offen ob
eine entscheidung über eine helmpflicht
getroffen wird für pflegekräfte und
krankenhauspersonal gibt es schon eine
impfpflicht die soll ab 15 märz gelten
gemeinsam beschlossen nun wollen die
ersten bundesländer schon verschieben
ich denke es gibt wirklich noch einige
wesentliche fragen im vollzug auch
dieser impfpflicht die gesundheitsämter
sollen ja da entscheiden wer macht was
an welcher stelle tätigkeitsverbote
werden ausgesprochen wie wird was
kontrolliert wie wird die versorgung
auch weiter sichergestellt ist eine ganz
zentrale frage ich höre da gerade aus
dem ambulanten bereich dass das große
schwierigkeiten gibt olaf scholz war
gegen die impfpflicht jetzt ist er da
für zweifel darf er nicht noch mal
aufkommen lassen selbst beschwörung
angesichts der tatsache dass die
impfquote in deutschland nicht so hoch
ist wie man hoffen durfte und dass sie
auch nicht hoch genug ist um den
ausreichenden schutz der bürgerinnen und
bürger zu gewährleisten haben viele ihre
meinung geändert in der politik aber wie
man ja in allen umfragen sehen kann auch
unter den bürgerinnen und bürgern
den zeitpunkt für den größten rückhalt
im land könnte scholz allerdings schon
verpasst haben als die krankenhäuser
ende des jahres alarm schlugen stieg die
zustimmung im november stark derzeit
singt sie wie auch die hoffnung bei den
kliniken weil wir erkennen dass
zunehmend offensichtlich die politik
unsicherer wird ob sie die impfpflicht
wirklich beschließen soll nachdem wir ja
am ende des vergangenen jahres noch eine
breite mehrheit und einen großen willen
bei der politik gespürt haben
noch wollen viele die impfpflicht
ministerpräsidenten olaf scholz auch
karl lauterbach kümmern soll sich das
parlament
dort machen sich ablehnung und
ratlosigkeit immer breiter